To start with, the viewport on
the phone is about 320 pixels,
which is 640 divided by 2.
For the phablet, or
the phone tablet, anything around
about 300 is going to be accepted.
Sometimes device manufacturers fudge
the numbers just a little bit,
which is going to give you fractions.
So, anything around 300's fine.
The tablet's pretty easy.
It's device pixel ratio is 1,
which means that its viewport
is the same size as its width.
So 1024 pixels.
And same thing for the laptop.
With a device pixel ratio of 1 and and
a browser width of 800 pixels, you'll
get a viewport width of 800 pixels.
Notice on the laptop that the whole
screen is larger than the browser.
But the viewport is only
about the browser's width,
not the whole screen, so
it's just 800 pixels.